according to a steam page that has since
been changed Star Wars Jedi Survivor
will be released in March 2023 but
during the time that the new steam page
was live some users reportedly saw the
date of March 15th While others saw the
date of March 16th according to a
previous report Jedi survivors release
date is scheduled to be officially
announced during the game awards later
this week a new trailer of the game will
also be shown at the event and the
potential release date isn't the only
thing that the steam page revealed there
were also images that showcased the
pre-order bonuses for different versions
of the game these items include new
looks for Cal and bd1 new lightsabers
and possibly the most exciting Edition
different blasker sets in Jedi Fallen
order Cal didn't have a gun in his
Loadout however it looks like this time
around that will change however don't
get too excited about these special
cosmetic items just yet because just
like the date they have not been
officially confirmed as of this
recording because we'll just have to
wait for the game awards for complete
confirmation of everything luckily for
us though Thursday is right around the
corner so we won't have to wait long and
on top of that we won't have to watch
the game awards for very long either as
Jeff Keeley has confirmed that the game
awards 2022 will be shorter than last
year's showcase during a recent Twitter
spaces talk Keely discussed the upcoming
ceremony and answered some questions
about what to expect the game awards is
usually filled with not only Awards
presentations but interviews with
developers and trailers for brand new
games last year's pre-show lasted around
30 minutes while the main event went on
for three hours during the spaces talk
Jeff said quote I won't say anything
officially until we're through our
rehearsals but we think it's going to be
significantly shorter the game awards
founder added that alongside the run
time being scaled down it will be
cutting back on games as well however
those tuning in can still expect quote
some some really great announcements
despite the shorter run time and there
will be some amazing Studios
participating this year and while you're
thinking about which of the world
premiere games you're excited to play in
the future keep in mind that gaming is
an expensive Hobby and this next story
is proof of that according to IGN Xbox
exclusives will cost 70 dollars at
launch but didn't elaborate on Regional
pricing for other countries in a
statement to the site Microsoft said
this price reflects the content scale
and Technical complexity of these titles
as with all games developed by our teams
at Xbox they will also be available with
game pass the same day they launch back
in October Xbox's Phil Spencer said that
certain Xbox products and services would
increase in price but not until after
the holidays while the price of Xbox
games will increase console prices and
Game Pass subscriptions have not yet
back in August Spencer mentioned that
Microsoft had no intention of raising
prices on consoles even though Sony did
for the PlayStation 5 five in countries
outside of the U.S however Spencer also
noted that plans can always change as
Microsoft continues to evaluate the
market hit the comments and let me know
what you think of the rising prices of
games and we'll see you in the next one